double zéro donc aller bien et granby et
noir vert le 16 juin dans un cinéma près
de chez vous alors si un film d'un genre
nouveau c'est le remake en france d'un
film américain exactement le résultat
est plutôt l inverse
voilà c'est un remake de spies like us
de john landis qui était avec chevy
chase et dan akroyd ça c'est une
initiative de thomas langmann qui est
venu nous voir et que ce dvd un jour une
nouvelle vie elles nous ont fait ça
ouais et comme ça en plus il voit dieu
sur ce ton là j'étais un jeune
producteur il a il est plus jeune que
nous quasiment et c'est je crois le plus
jeune producteur au monde
ouais non mais c'est vrai en plus rapide
et le souple ce fut musée le plus propre
et l'hygiène impeccable incroyable bien
l'oeil à edouard baer dans ce film aussi
alors il s'est fait la tête de davies
ward le copain de ma mère c'est marrant
goût du jazz que dans sa tête et il a
fait le look de peuvent des 10 ne
connais pas bien le lac combal sommes un
peu c'est vrai à mike myers dans austin
powers mais surtout à des stewards se
trouve là la moitié d'eurythmics il a
une poupe effectivement de footballeurs
des années 80 absolument comme eric
rochant delany lennox gros budget pour
ce feeling incroyable le club des cinq
marins tournage aux quatre coins du
monde à monaco à londres saint tropez
venezuela les huées la russie en russie
partout c'est un film comme on verra
mais des effets spéciaux des gonds 16
ans s'est dit là les jeunes vont aller
au cinéma là il faut leur en donner à
leur isolement pour l'heure là il faut
qu'ils s'asseyent le seul petit truc
faut qu'il rajoute un petit peu pour
s'acheter des pop corn
ouais là la soirée à lille nickel et et
ya dixinn qu'est ce qu'elle est belle
parce incroyablement d'un jeu comprend
on part volontiers au boulot le matin
donc yannick since au plateau un transit
et
n'oublions mobile à petit la petite et
l'album à filtrer dès que l'on parle de
ma fille moi il y avait une blague il ya
plus d'humains qui extraient les
shampoings ouais mais les promesses mais
les gentils
oh
le taxi
voilà ça c'est l'un des candidats par
wesh momo wesh wesh mot hexagonal qui
est extrait de la bande originale du
film double zéro avec eric et l'anzhi
edouard baer dans un cinéma près de chez
vous le 16 juin et où la promo ça va
comme ça le rend très bien également
matt sur la bande ne vois là il ya kool
shen le sien il ya diane ci a des atouts
il y avait du monde en emilie romagne
paul ya basta plex ont fait très fière
elle est très riche et que tu es que des
hans a fini de le dire c'est que des
gens creusent m mais c'est vrai
bah
non
alors vous avez déclaré eric et ramzy
des savanes qu'est la seule interview à
peu près 100 c'est que les données
depuis la sortie de ce film c'est sûr
que je ne vois pas elisabeth quin dire
que ce film-là touché profondément
à moins qu'elle ait pris la cassette
dans la gueule non nous allons rajouter
quel rapport entre elizabeth cinéma j'ai
pas compris parce qu'ils avaient quitté
le cinéma c'est bien force est plus
lente à l'asie le temps gym et
eschatologique
c'est vrai risque alors que survienne a
tous les défauts de la terre sauf
celui-là
non mais je pense que nous on a on a on
n'a pas forcément les critiques avec
nous c'est la tour montparnasse c'était
pas le film le plus insensé de la
critique mais on préfère être à voir du
public que d'avoir des critiques ouais
que d'avoir des bonnes
le jour où on aura des hauts il dit
c'est là qu'il faudra pour nous c'est un
cliché mais elle est très fière de ma
nature de ce qu on fait quoi
il a peut-être qu'elle va trouver ça
bien isabelle camus ne savais pas ça
sera non mais on n'a aucun grief contre
elisabeth quin son métier ses tours non
mais on n'est jamais rencontré ni rien
mais c'est vrai que
voilà c'est pas du lars von trier nous
c'est un film on appelle ça un film pop
corn c'est vraiment le film on vient on
s'assoit on regarde pendant une heure et
demie un truc on en prend plein la
gueule
il ya des vannes il ya des meufs des
explosions il ya une histoire qui trace
et voila quoi ces gens on a vu dans les
films à la à l'archet ta gueule
permanent vérité soit une amérique en
asie et là je pourrai jamais ça y est
mon côté m'énerve
ouais je crois qu'il veut venir vers toi
un peu d'erreurs de lui à dégager les
gens
mais on est très fan de films à la world
boss voilà on a essayé de le faire en
français donne à tête on est égoïste
mais voilà ils ont par deux entre les
deux sens en décembre les dalton qui
serait de vider halton on a beaucoup
d'argent si 27 millions de l'unique
double jours mais ne parlons pas
d'argent parlons de films de
divertissement s'est retiré ses partants
d'argent de combien ça coûte
c'est beaucoup mais en même temps je
vais faire une sacrée merde avec 25
millions elle regarde en février vont
remonter sur scène à partir du 2 février
à l'olympia et science de la proue de la
date là les places sont déjà en vente
ouais nous sommes attendus et pas dans
deux rues encore donc tu peux nous et
des colliers et c'est prêt contrairement
à élie semoun vous refusé de chanter à 2
contrairement à beaucoup de gens agnès
jaoui cauterets a également failli du
monde qui chanta maintenant apparemment
mais bon dans la même catégorie à marvin
gaye à barry white ousanousava non mais
t'as fait on a des 10 de marvin gaye on
se permettra pas de changement donc
contrairement à élie semoun l'on refusé
de chanter contrairement à dieudonné
vous vous refusez de vous mêler de
politique
c'est la blague la blague la blague
internationaux que nous sommes à la
recherche de la blague
merci mais contrairement à elie et
dieudonné vous refusez de vous séparer
on s'adore
bon je kiffe c'est un vrai problème il
est parti d'un problème pour ma femme
ah ouais n'en peut plus c'est à dire
cette année on est resté huit mois
ensemble
oui je rentrais chez moi j'ai embrassé
ma nounou moi je suis resté ma femme on
va voir si votre amitié c'est du solide
interview zizanie